look at Shania Twain is right behind the
lessons oh my gosh you guys look great
this is amazing I'm starstruck I'm
starstruck this is great I don't know
what to say yes between the icons this
is amazing I can't believe this
happening I thought I was gonna be early
no one's gonna be here and I saw you I'm
like I'm gonna go home now
remix right here I don't impress me much
me I love that I already did a remix I
play it every night I have a remix of
that song already we're gonna send it
over to you and then we'll do something
new to accept your gift mister dip and
I'll keep Shania that's what happens I
didn't know he was gonna be wearing a
cowboy hat you look freaking amazing
what is this fashion this is Marc Bouwer
who is my favorite of all time longtime
friends and jockey Lemieux my jewelry I
wish you had more diamonds on Shania
it's not enough these are antiques
actually they're all entities you look
insane I feel like this could be a
celebration party for your opening night
oh absolutely this is a prelude to
what's to come
I've mashed it up a bit and it's it's
very colorful and fun and I think it's
just very Shania today and it's still
you know touching back on the classics
and the traditional should I have it
yeah I have to say we all grew up too
including myself
I love crop tops crop tops shinai as my
favorite shinai you invented the crop
top back then I want to ask you about
the residency do you feel the pressure
are you so excited
oh no no pressure I'm ready I'm having a
great time I'm I've been so involved
with the production about from the
beginning that that takes the pressure
off because it's like studying for exams
you know I I feel like I wrote the exam
and I just have to get out there and
percentage tailors being honored tonight
with artists of the decade and you've
been someone who's really stood up for
her and spoken out about her talent what
why do you think she's so deserving
Taylor is the epitome of a hard worker
talent you don't have to be beautiful to
be star but she carries her beauty with
so much grace and without flaunting and
I think she's just a very special person
she's dedicated serious and she's just a
badass woman
yeah I saw on Instagram you posted a
throwback to your very first AMA is what
do you remember from that night well I'm
just probably a lot more nervous than 96
oh man I didn't even have a child yet I
mean there's so much that has happened
I've lived so much since then and I'm
feeling much more comfortable in my skin
and I stand here I walk this red carpet
and I'll watch the show tonight and
looking at new artists that were just
little kids when I first came out and
I'm so proud of them I'm proud of Taylor
I'm proud of post Malone and all these
old underparts so I'm really a fan of
what's going on in music right now and
I'm just watching us as a proud dad and
a proud Mutual artist
[Music]